no not really I mean it's growing in
respect there's artistry in it I you
know there's moments when it becomes an
art form but it's still on the body and
there is a part to it that has even in
the most far-out gowns that you'd make a
utilitarianism to it it sits in the
present nature of it whether it can be
abstract or not you're still talking
about it in relation on the body when
you move off the body then it will reach
the level of respect forming a brand in
itself can be an art form and can is a
respected art I believe and you know it
becomes you know part of culture it's
sort of it's it's the be it besides the
craft in the artistry of it it goes it's
it's not I don't consider it a a fine
art
you